hey 42 here some people are born to do
just one thing and one thing only
lionel messi was meant to be a
footballer wolfgang amadeus mozart was
made to write music and albert einstein
was born to change our understanding of
the universe
robert james fisher
he was placed on planet earth to play
chess
this man was quite simply a phenomenon
he broke every record in the book during
a meteoric rise to the top of his sport
game
well sport but also a game
look i don't know what it is but he was
really good at it
so good that's at the peak of his powers
american prodigy bobby fisher
single-handedly took on the might of the
soviet chess machine a state-sponsored
juggernaut that had monopolized
international chess for two and a half
decades
and won
in doing so he demonstrated a level of
dominance over the world's strongest
players that had never been seen before
and hasn't been seen since
but fischer didn't only have to contend
with his grandmaster opponents he also
battled with his own inner demons
having scaled the dizzying heights of
the chess equivalent of mount everest to
become the undisputed best player on
earth
fisher threw it all away as his growing
paranoia and distrust
saw him all but abandon the game he
dedicated his life to as his behavior
grew more and more erratic he eventually
found himself a fugitive from the law
and an exile from the country he'd
brought so much glory to
this is the remarkable true story of
bobby fischer
arguably the greatest genius chess has
ever seen
based on genes alone fischer was always
going to be bright his mother regina
held a phd in medicine and spoke seven
languages fluently and his father
hermann was a biophysicist or at least a
man people thought was his father was a
biophysicist
it turns out there's an extremely good
chance bobby was actually the product of
an affair his mother had with hungarian
mathematician and physicist paul nemeny
either way it's safe to say nature was
on his side
though things were a bit complicated on
the nurture front
bobby was technically homeless when he
was born in 1943
and with his parents separated he and
his sister joan were brought up by their
mother
regina was a complex woman extremely
politically active she was routinely
investigated by the fbi for her
suspected communist links
bobby was never particularly close to
his mum and when he was just 16 she left
him to live on his own in one of the
most dangerous neighborhoods in brooklyn
as she pursued her medical career which
i'm guessing ahead of myself this story
really begins when bobby was just six
years old because that's when he
discovered the game that would change
his life
it was his sister who bought the chess
set and the two of them learned how the
pieces moved from the instructions
included in the box to begin with it was
a bit of fun but over time bobby's
thoughts turned to chess more and more
often
within a year what had started out as a
hobby had turned into an all-consuming
obsession at least it had for bobby his
sister had largely lost interest leaving
him with no one to play with not that he
minded all that much he just played with
himself
not like that
it was two years later that bobby fisher
first showed up as the faintest of blips
on the us chess radar
noting her son's passion for the game
but a little concerned about how much
time he was spending playing alone
regina placed an advert in a local paper
seeking possible opponents and ideally
friends for bobby what she got was even
better he was invited to take part in a
match against one of the strongest
players in the us at the time
max pavey it was to be a so-called
simultaneous exhibition with pavi
demonstrating his prodigious skills by
playing against a large group of players
all at the same time if you're expecting
this story to start with a miracle
victory against a chess master
i'm afraid i'm going to have to
disappoint you pavey put bobby away in
about 15 minutes
but whilst it was an easy victory the
self-taught seven-year-old had acquitted
himself remarkably well
so well that the president of the
brooklyn chess club also present at the
exhibition decided to take bobby in
under his wing offering a little tuition
and introducing him to his club it was
the break bobby had needed to take his
game to the next level and surrounded by
skillful coaches and strong players he
began to improve at an almost
unbelievable rate
he won his first tournament at the age
of nine
and was soon more than a match for most
players at the club the majority of whom
were decades his senior
in the summer of 1956 when bobby was
just 13 he scored his first major
victory becoming the youngest u.s junior
chess champion in history
it was an incredible achievement by any
measure
but fisher was just getting started
later that same year he was invited to
play an elite level competition
featuring the 12 strongest players in
the us at the time
bobby was by far the youngest player in
the field and hugely inexperienced
compared to his opponents
which is probably why he only managed to
finish eighth
but he didn't come away empty-handed he
was awarded the so-called brilliancy
prize for winning his game against
international chess master donald byrne
today that victory is known as the game
of the century
it was an attacking master class in
which a 13 year old fisher playing as
black sacrificed his queen before
unleashing a devastating mating attack
on white's king
more than 60 years later it remains one
of the most studied and admired chess
games in history
it was fast becoming clear that fisher
was more than just a strong young player
he was something truly special
fisher was competing with men decades
older than him who dedicated their lives
to chess
and he was winning by the following year
he was u.s chess champion
the youngest in history at just 14
a record that still stands to this day
he will go on to play a further seven
u.s championships over the next decade
winning
every single one of them
by 15 fisher had earned himself the
title of grand master once again
becoming the youngest person in history
to achieve that feat his dedication to
the game of chess was mind-boggling he
studied almost non-stop and played
whenever he got the chance he even
taught himself basic russian so that he
could read soviet chess books and
magazines
he was actually still a schoolboy at
this point of course
but it's fair to say he didn't take his
non-chess education particularly
seriously
fisher dropped out of the school system
at 16. the earliest he could legally do
so to focus on his chess full-time
by the way in a completely unrelated and
totally random bit of trivia it turns
out bobby fischer went to school with
barbra streisand and neil diamond
streisand has even admitted to having a
crush on the future chess champion who
she considered to be a genius even then
as it happens she was right fish's iq
was later measured at over 180
which is astonishingly high
even at this early stage of his career
there were signs that not all was well
with fisher
he was temperamental and prone to making
outlandish demands of tournament
organizers
when those demands weren't met and they
often weren't
he simply didn't show up
he also had a bad habit of speaking his
mind
which wouldn't necessarily have been a
bad thing
but unfortunately fischer's undeniably
beautiful mind
was home to some rather ugly ideas
despite the fact his mother was jewish
fischer was a fierce anti-semite for
most of his adult life a prejudice that
would later become an obsession
and he's on record as having said some
truly unforgivable things particularly
as he got older
but more on that later
it was sad really because when he let
his chest rather than his mouth do the
talking
bobby fisher's eloquence was
unparalleled
his combative approach to tournament
officials had a severely detrimental
effect on his career in the 60s and he
went for long stretches without playing
any competitive chess at all to give you
an idea of how stubborn he was on one
occasion he started a prestigious
tournament
then withdrew halfway through whilst in
the lead because of a scheduling dispute
not only did he forfeit a probable
tournament win the decision directly
prevented him from challenging for
chess's ultimate prize the world
championship for several years
afterwards
despite frequently pushing the
self-destruct button fisher did
eventually get his shot at the world
championship in the early 70s the timing
was perfect too because fisher was just
coming into the form of his life he
earned the right to play the world
champion at the time soviet grand master
boris spassky by winning the candidates
tournament during which he annihilated
grand master mark tamanov 6-0 in the
quarter-finals
then repeated defeat by sweeping danish
gm bent larson 6-0 in the semis
score lines like those basically don't
exist at the top level of chess where
the majority of games between strong
players end in draws
fischer had already been on a ridiculous
winning streak going into the candidates
tournament
and after winning his first game against
legendary soviet gm tigran petrosian in
the final he'd won a total of 20 games
in a row against the world's best
players
if you follow chess you'll know how
absurd that number is
at the time former world champion
mikhail bodfinig described it as a
miracle
if you don't follow chess let me just
put it this way nobody has come even
remotely close to matching that kind of
winning streak in the modern history of
the game
and there's a very good chance nobody
ever will it should have been impossible
it was impossible but bobby fischer did
it anyway
it's really hard to put into context
just how insane fischer's performance
was during this period but let me try
norwegian grand master magnus carlson is
the best chess player on earth today
he's a five-time world champion and his
head and shoulders above any other
player in the world
most people agree by the time he retires
he'll avert the right to call himself
the best chess player ever
carlson currently sits a whopping 60
rating points ahead of the second
highest ranked player in the world
teenage sensation ali rizzer ferrugia
it's a huge margin that accurately
reflects carlson's dominance over the
rest of the field but here's the thing
bobby fisher was the highest ranked
player in the world in the early 70s
and after his 20-game winning streak he
was
125 rating points ahead of his closest
rival
the man he would soon face in the world
championship match boris baskey
as i said carlson is on track to become
the greatest chess player in history
but there are close to 20 players within
125 rating points of him right now
of course it's a different era and
direct comparisons are difficult
but the point is this
at no point in chess history has any
player been so much better than his
rivals as fisher was in the early 70s
it was like he was playing a different
game
despite the ratings gap the 1972 world
championship match
wasn't a foregone conclusion by any
means
just like fisher spassky is widely
regarded as one of the best chess
players ever
and at the time he also happened to be
one of the few players in world chess
with a favorable record against the
american they'd only played on five
occasions but spassky had won three of
them with the other games ending in
draws
spassky also had another huge advantage
on his side he was backed by the
state-sponsored soviet chess machine
that had brought so much success in
previous decades
he went into the match with a whole team
of extremely strong grandmasters working
on his behalf analyzing fisher's games
writing reports probing for weaknesses
and preparing lines of attack designed
to catch fisher off guard
fischer had none of that
just the help of his second american
grandmaster william lombardi
the chess world was buzzing in the
build-up to the match not just a chess
world actually for the first time and
possibly only time in history chess was
front page news helped by the fact the
cold war was in full swing at the time
adding a lay of political intrigue to
the usa ussr face-off
but before the match even got underway
fisher was up to his old tricks arguing
over where it should be held and
demanding that the prize fund be
significantly increased
the start of the match was delayed by
two days as fisher refused to play
but luckily a wealthy british investment
banker donated a large sum to bolster
the prize fund and the venue was
eventually agreed upon reykjavik iceland
if anyone had been under any illusions
about whether spassky could match fisher
they were quickly dispelled spassky beat
the seemingly unbeatable american in the
very first game of a scheduled 24. he
won the second game too but this time
thanks to a forfeit after fischer
surprising nobody refused to play
there was huge media attention on the
match and fischer felt the massed tv
cameras recording the game for worldwide
audiences had put him off he demanded
that the second game be moved to a more
private location
when it wasn't
he didn't show up
the match would probably have ended
right there had spassky not intervened
in an admirable show of sportsmanship
rather than simply take the title and
move on
the soviet champion asked that fish's
demands be met so the match could
continue the rest is history
despite being two nil down which would
typically be seen as a huge deficit in
the finely balanced world of chess
fisher won seven of the following 19
games
losing only once and drawing 11 times it
was a crushing victory that saw fisher
crowned the 11th world chess champion
his performance throughout was so
remarkable that after a particularly
brilliant win in game six even boris
spassky stood to applaud his opponent
along with the fans
considering his playing strength at the
time there's every reason to believe
fisher could have dominated the sport
for years perhaps even decades to come
but
nobody got the chance to find out just
how far he could have gone in 1975 he
was due to defend his world title
against a young soviet grand master
anatoly karpov
but once again fischer issued a string
of demands prior to the match
some of which were fairly reasonable
others of which
not so much
when only some of the demands were met
fisher once again walked away
this time forfeiting the title
he wouldn't play another competitive
game of chess in public
for the next 20 years
say what you want about fisher that guy
really knew how to hold a grudge he
practically became a recluse and not an
awful lot is known about his movements
over the following decades though he did
get himself involved in a doomsday cult
called the worldwide church of god
the group believed the world would end
in 1975
but when that year came and went with a
notable lack of apocalypses fisher along
with many other members moved on
[Music]
his first competitive game after two
decades in the wilderness was a rematch
with spassky held in 1992 in yugoslavia
fisher won with relative ease
but along with a huge paycheck he also
got himself into trouble with the law
at the time there was a united nations
embargo against commercial activities in
yugoslavia and the match was deemed to
be a violation fisher knew full well
what he was doing was illegal during a
live news conference in the build-up he
took out a cease and desist letter sent
to him by his own government and spat on
it in front of the world's press the
us's response was equally emphatic
though a little less unhygienic a
warrant was issued for fisher's arrest
not keynes who faced a fallout that
awaited him in america
fisher would never again return to his
homeland living instead in hungary and
japan though he did almost get himself
deported after being arrested for
traveling on an expired passport in
2004.
the incident saw him imprisoned in japan
for nine months during which time his
old foe boris spassky made a personal
plea for the then u.s president george w
bush to intervene in the case
when that failed spassky offered to join
fischer in his cell on the condition
that the two were given a chess set
ultimately fisher managed to persuade
the government of iceland to offer him
full citizenship and he lived out the
rest of his days in reykjavik the site
of his great triumph over spassky
he died there in 2008 at the age of 64.
understandably fisher is still idolized
by many as one of the true greats in the
history of chess
a genius and an enigma in equal measure
fischer played the game in a way that
had never been seen before
but it has to be said that being really
good at something isn't an excuse for
doing or saying terrible things
and bobby fischer was certainly guilty
of that at times in his life you don't
have to dig too deep on the internet to
uncover some genuinely abhorrent quotes
about jews women america and basically
anything else that ended up in his
crosshairs
by the end of his life he was utterly
convinced the world was run by an evil
jewish conspiracy and that the us
government was out to get him
he also thought modern chess matches
were all fixed and that computers had
killed the game in what may be his most
famous outburst just hours after the
world trade center terror attacks in
2001
fischer gave a phone interview
applauding the acts of the terrorists
and celebrating the death and
destruction they'd caused
understandably considering his erratic
and paranoid behavior and his extremist
views many people believe fisher
suffered from some form of mental
illness
it certainly seems possible but he was
never formally assessed so we don't know
for sure
the people who knew him well and
there weren't many mostly seemed to
agree that he was misunderstood and
misrepresented by the press
though it has to be said that many of
the worst things to come out of his
mouth are a matter of public record
setting aside the controversy for a
moment there's no denying that fisher
was a genuinely remarkable chess player
gary kasparov won the world chess
championship six times and magnus
carlsen currently sits on five wins
it's a testament to just how great
fischer was at his best that his name is
uttered alongside those legends of the
game
despite his relatively short career and
single world championship victory you'll
struggle to find many all-time best
chess player lists that have fisher
outside of the top three he may not have
played for long but at his peak he was
simply untouchable in a sport where
draws are the expected result bobby
james fisher blasted world chess
opponents off the board like they were
mere children
whatever you may think of the man he
became there's no denying he was made to
play chess
thanks for
watching you